avec casimir je te parie que tu montres
pas celui-là cran cubic tu as devant toi
l'avant centre dans l'équipe du brésil
ac a bon ben moi je suis le goal du
bayern de munich
haha tu vas voir à temps sur mes chers
auditeurs toute l'équipe du brésil est
en attaque un centre superbe arrive dans
les pieds de l'avant-centre casimir à
eau
il dégage magnifiquement se débarrasse
des deux arrières échoue imparablement
dit midi donc il est pas terrible
l'avant-centre de l'équipe du brésil je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé françois
je crois que c'est parce que j'ai un peu
faim je vais chez moi non j'ai un peu de
glace aux anchois que je reviens tu
verras si je suis à l'avant centre
minable à tout à leur champion
tout à l'heure bon ben en fait de
ballons il faudrait peut-être que je
m'occupe des 1001 que ces paumés mais
que c'est beau mais si monsieur
travelling lui-même cheikh hamid ben
mahi que trouvez-vous si beau monsieur
travelling nouveau ballon une harmonie
de couleurs à sens des formes assez ça
faisait beaucoup de talent nous voulions
monsieur travelling les les ballons sont
ce qu'ils sont il n'est pas question de
talent l'aide d'un arrêt si je vous
assure garder ouais sever à côté de
cette orange à vous savez je les ai mis
comme ça sans réfléchir au thème du port
vous avez vu ces deux ballons côte à
côte comme ça du premier coup mais je
vous assure enfin c'est le hasard
je vous en prie laisser la za de côté la
preuve est faite vous avez un instinct
artistique unique
le mot n'est pas trop fort je suis très
flatté de votre jugement mais ce
travelling et c'est vrai en
réfléchissant bien cet ange et ceux vers
l'un à côté de l'autre c'est formidable
et le rouge la balle rouge à côté de
leur bon mais que je fais au challenge
mais c'est vrai et dire que j'aime été
comme ça sans réfléchir à les grands
artistes connaissent jamais la véritable
étendue de leur talent mais je pense il
ya des galeries d'art à paris à londres
des groupes de ballons ainsi disposer de
rendre les fortunes je le croyais
vraiment laissé certains voyons je vais
me faire une proposition
oui laquelle vous préparez des ensembles
de ballons comme celui ci je les emporte
avec moi je les expose et nous
partageons prix de la vente
c'est je ne connais pas grand chose dans
les affaires mais en tout cas je veux
bien essayer parfait j'établis le
contrat je reviens aux ânes astreignant
une dernière chose il ya ces gentils
d'aller chercher casimir il est temps
que ce grand artiste signe lui aussi son
encontre
je crois monsieur travelling que vous
perdez votre temps il n'acceptera jamais
c'est que c'était intéressant pour moi
c'est de m'occuper de vous deux votre
contrat sans celui de kazemi on n'est ce
pas enfin comprenez je vous comprends
très bien monsieur travelling que
j'étais stupide de vous croire mais le
ballon lui rien d'extraordinaire mais
non mais vous voulez vous servir de moi
tant que je vous aide à faire signer le
contrat de casimir tout ce que vous
voulez c'est gagner beaucoup d'argent
n'est ce pas beaucoup d'argent devant
des cassini à travers le monde dans une
cage comme a nourri des gros monstres
mais voyons enfin sais pas si je veux je
travaille et qui te n'aimait pas longue
et bien je vous laisse les admirer
regardez les et moi je vais de ce pas
prévenir casimir de votre arrivée
je vais lui dire de semer petit vous
avons fait part ça je vous quitte
monsieur presque réussi monsieur
travelling je crois oui c'est moi j'ai
entendu dire que vous étiez
organisateurs de spectacles et que vous
désiriez engagé casimir
on vous en faites pas j'ai abandonné
définitivement au mais vous avez tour
c'est une excellente idée
vous devez l'engager france est vraiment
mais oui et je suis même prête à vous
aider
mais quelles petites sommes intelligents
nous avons à une condition ah oui
m'engager avec le vis oh mais aucun
problème aucun problème vous serez
merveilleuse dans le spectacle j'avais
tout j'étais dire des écoutes et tu te
rends ciardi des troubles et membres
bages dit cet animal plein de rage qui
sera châtié de ta témérité n'avait rien
de moins en fin de plus
oh je sais danser aussi balèze physique
[Musique]
là
vous
[Musique]
ce n'est vraiment faire de spectacle
mais monsieur travelling la situation
est claire
casimir et moi ou pas de kazimiya du
tout bon ben alors autre chose autre
chose
moi je vais vous chanter quelques sueurs
bah oui aller
non pas ça ah non pas ça ah non pas ça
non